hello and welcome to this video playing
tube or do I get a banker we followed
the rare guys who actually is willing to
play a real game there and not play III
c 3 and try to be boring so check I
actually think i had this on the book
what what what happened I did not have
93 on the radio at all I was to
basically pretty moving before okay so
what is the deal actually if I hope it
should a six what is what is happening
here there's some trick line that I
don't understand 23-yard what help so I
take it he go special detour Wow
check ah it seems that this is a lion
IAM great hmm i don't don't really
remember this stuff and it doesn't look
good to be honest that doesn't look good
my development is non-existent shoot
yeah i was pre moving before for
heaven's sake yeah this looks like
closely this looks losing actually I
don't think I I think I'm lost Queen B 6
rue k3 threatens bishop he threatens
Bishop a five and that should win priced
I totally hate this kind of thing and I
actually think that this line is rubbish
which is just a personal opinion but ok
there are people who like it forward
like shundor Phineas books but anyway so
Bishop a5 is the problem so if i go
queen to be seven at least this i can
answer with Bishop takes on 35 what's
going on here Queen a4 maybe or what to
see what is he doing now and I create
five maybe I'm still two more pool two
moves away from class awning and
g6 already looks like a luxury ok I
think I had to play this move here
Bishop see dream but now i can take
thick you can hate takes Bishop takes
and the position is bad but
[Music]
96
yeah I have to I probably have to be
5-10 oh I cannot actually take 125
because of Queen g5 God uh-huh quite a
bad position so it can take these six
and take a six I really hate this this
kind of stuff now is now is trying to
trying to totally demoralize me here
with the Queen sacrifice hey this
terrible it's rattling okay aid is the
problem I mean the whites position is so
good you can do that it was completely
unnecessary but it is probably good
enough
changes when I'm learning one by normal
means but I also have a huge time
disadvantage should a five Bishop c7
might be good
I mean he hears them he doesn't have
anything developed in on this side of
the board Bishop h3 that's actually well
played that says if that is his idea
it's not maybe just g5 yeah anyway I I
have to play booze I'm in a case all
this fancy sacrifices he just has
misplayed it completely but I don't know
so this one okay that's nice I cannot
take it okay maybe this this shot does
actually do the trick
still he did not ever have to sacrifice
anything okay okay I threatened to check
and play Queen f2 will actually still
slightly tricky here no it's not so easy
fun a thing check no I'm threatening
Queen h1 he might take here and whatever
but doesn't really kill me I think Queen
Queen here is a threat Queen h 120
seconds
will be very difficult to manage this
with the time situation and only place
the maunder just it's kind of composing
myself for a second check check my
answer team moving takes it takes with
the night now I can actually get to five
maybe check check check
eight seconds check check yeah I know he
got a chance he forged now that was
pretty terrible black forfeits on town
gage she tricked me in the opening and
that led to this this time this time
issues didn't really matter that he
completely screwed it up I had 93 holy
heck yeah everybody plays Bishop tutu
year after which before is the move and
this totally irritated me I don't know
maybe I still play this smooth but yeah
I have alternatives i have c for
whatever there's a typical blitz trick
this this is this is getting really
annoying you this stuff and that
probably bishop a six is bad why just
continue now maybe t-taking is wrong
right this is wrong check now the taking
is wrong just something something like
that I really irritated Chang to no end
yeah this position is lost there I can
can get known as a sin I mean okay
what's he I could have taken yeah why
did i do that i actually overlooked that
I mean okay I can do that but I felt
this this is completely unnecessary of
course you can play whatever Queen 85 by
winning or what I mean just decide a sec
it's still an extremely annoying
position to
because of my no no coordination yeah
all I didn't see neither seven check
okay i have 20 seconds chang all kinds
of crap check and still win here the
position of course wins for black but i
have 15 seconds yeah i really got too
much irritated in the opening and didn't
keep a cool head down that that I kind
of ya did it free that up remix this
basically it it's not that bad but it
totally irritated me oh ok guys thanks
for watching
[Music]